back now at 7 30 in the white house said
this week it supports the study of
reparations for black americans in
congress
h.r 40 that's a bill would examine the
history of slavery and discriminatory
government policies
and suggest ways to address inequality
consider this the typical white
household
as about 10 times the accumulated wealth
of the typical black household
it's an issue we began looking into last
summer on the campaign trail and we
found what many scholars say
is the root of this racial wealth gap
it's not entirely in slavery or some
century old wrong
but in fact in the modern suburbs and it
touches on my own family's history
in 1953 my grandfather rudy decopal
became a homeowner moving my grandmother
and three kids including my dad
out of a tiny apartment in manhattan and
into a new house in lynhurst new jersey
one of america's growing suburbs after
world war ii
millions of families made a similar move
families are pursuing
the american dream to give their
children a better chance in life a lot
of them were masons
carpenters farmers working class
working class proudly so definitely bob
janjarusso is the mayor of lynnhurst and
a lifelong resident
we had great childhood here it's
priceless
one of the best places you could ever
imagine to grow up and joe cafone a
retired police officer
is an unofficial town historian it
sounds like a classic
american suburb that's it that's exactly
that's a that's a really good way to put
it
but america's suburbs have another story
less often told
about who was able to buy these homes
and benefit from that boom time economy
and who is not it's just a remarkable
record of exclusion
david trout is a law professor at
rutgers university newark
it is not accidental and it is not just
a question of bad attitudes
it's a question about inequitable rules
from the 1930s to the 1960s the major
federal programs that developed the
suburbs and
guaranteed mortgages were for whites
only
first as a matter of policy and later in
practice
redlining for example is a term that
comes from these 1940s era maps
adopted by the federal housing authority
green blue
and yellow areas were typically eligible
for government-backed loans and
investment the red areas were not
leaving them starved for resources
and as i looked back at lynhurst and the
surrounding county where my
great-grandparents also owned a home
i noticed those red-lined areas had a
lot in common
they were anywhere from 45 percent to 95
percent negro
the term used some had wells spoiled by
typhoid
some did not have city gas
or utilities going to all the properties
some were
divided off by a railroad line or an
elevated train so
physical segregation in addition to
everything else any that surprise you
not at all in fact you can multiply
those findings across the country
those who were fortunate enough to enjoy
the largesse of this government
were able to see benefits accrue over
generations which they could then share
with their children and their
grandchildren
and so to be left out of that process of
household wealth accumulation
has been devastating for black families
by 1950 about half the new home
purchases in america were made with
government-backed loans
but 98 percent of them went to white
buyers
and among veterans like my grandfather
in the lucrative new york new jersey
area
it was more than 99 percent it's an
uncomfortable fact that families like
mine
are only just beginning to face wait a
minute you're telling me
they were only going to mortgage white
people yeah
yeah for you to say that lynhurst is the
way it is because
it almost implies that leonards was
racist no this is my family too i'm not
saying that
i'm saying that we i'm saying we had no
idea you're right most people would not
have known that the federal government
had this program in place
a lot of people did not know but a lot
of people
lee porter among them were personally
physically aware that race's policies
prevented black families from moving
into highly desired neighborhoods
i didn't call it redlining but yeah
that's what it was what did you call it
we call it this is the area that persons
of color can live
at 94 years old porter still runs the
fair housing council of bergen county
you've been called the mother of fair
housing
in new jersey i don't know how i don't
know how that happened
she's been here since the 1960s when she
and her husband were blocked from buying
homes
they could afford how did you feel when
you found out
that real estate agents were steering
you away
from the white houses i was quite angry
about it
but i was persistent i was
i was determined to get what i wanted
the same as anybody else
quite angry sounds like an
understatement
uh we managed we did okay but black
families who couldn't own those nicer
homes have not been able to build the
same wealth over time
many americans me included are only just
now coming to terms with how big a role
our federal government had
in enforcing discrimination the question
now is
what are we going to do about it the one
thing that i'm struggling with
and this is as as somebody whose family
came through here
is when i looked at the old maps just
over the river
the areas were redlined by the federal
government
meaning they weren't worthy of mortgages
and lindhurst wasn't redlined what do
you do with that knowledge
you move on come on it's all god's
people
now that we do know right what do we do
about it
you know that's a good question i don't
have the answer to that tony i wish i
did
i don't know that's a very honest answer
too what are we going to do about it
that's jaw dropping to me
98 percent yeah 99 in in this area
went to white families 99 so it begins
the wealth gap
that is the origin of the racial wealth
gap in this country this is where
history shows up in your wallet
yeah and uh you know bob and joe who i
appreciate having a very difficult and
uncomfortable conversation with me
they're representative of where most
white americans are today 80 or 90
percent
don't know what to do about it or think
we should just start today and be better
in the future
but how do we do how do you catch up
though how do you catch up it's like
it's like okay we've been running a race
yeah and now we're gonna follow the
rules of the race
but don't worry about the head start yes
yeah it's a real
dilemma because it because it compounded
as you as you point out in the piece
over generations
it's it's not just one family lost
opportunity that goes on to their
to their descendants and the descendants
after them and it's gone on you know for
decades and continues
your professor said it right a
remarkable record of exclusion
but can we just take a moment to
acknowledge lee porter i bow down to her
what a class class actually she is the
is the woman who got corey senator cory
booker's family was in bergen county and
got in
through her work i didn't know it was
her yeah so it's an amazing piece
thank you a lot of people need to see
that piece tonight ask ourselves what
are we going to do about it the white
house is asking americans to consider it
to study it